[Musique]
les 15 16 et 17 novembre dernier la
Réunion accueillit la première édition
des Rencontres des solidarités des
outremèes organisé par l'Union nationale
des centres communaux d'action sociale
au programme de ces TR jours des tables
rondes des ateliers de travail
décentralisés dans les CCAS de Lille
mais aussi un salon réunissant 30
exposants agissant dans le champ de
l'action sociale ces rencontres de
solidarité sont l'occasion de rencontrer
tous les acteurs aussi bien de la
Réunion comme des autres outrem mais
aussi des acteurs nationaux qui
travaillent B dans les CCAS à mettre en
place des politiques de proximité des
politiques de solidarité et on a besoin
de montrer ce que nous faisons à la
réunion de même qu'on a besoin de voir
ce qui se fait ailleurs pour pouvoir
nous enrichir mutuellement le
département est présent bien évidemment
parce que nous finanons sont aussi une
part des actions des CCS à travers le
PACT de solidarité territoriale pour
l'occasion quelques 300 acteurs des CCAS
ultramarins ont fait le déplacement sur
notre île venu notamment de Mayotte de
Guadeloupe de Martinique de Guyanne et
de Nouvelle-Calédonie le département de
La Réunion en tant que chef de fil de
l'action sociale sur le territoire a
également participé à ces rencontres
nous avons voulu maintenant il y a un an
coconstruire avec l'ensemble de nos
unions départements mental et
territorial le programme des 3 jours
pour finalement partager des problèmes
qui sont communs à tous il faut voir
comment on apporte plus et mieux de
réponses par rapport à l'Hexagone
surtout nous allons proposer parce que
il suffit pas d'être dans le dans le
constat nous on va faire en sorte qu'on
va parler d'une même voix même s'il y a
comme je disais un curseur à mettre à un
endroit différent selon le sujet et
selon le territoire et je suis persuadé
quand je vois le dynamisme ici depuis 3
jours l'envie et ben ça ne peut
qu'avancer à l'issue des 3 jours
d'atelier et d'échang l'uncas a annoncé
la création d'un réseau ultramarin au
sein de l'Union nationale qui réunira
adhérant union départementale et
territoriale en collaboration avec le
compasse un bureau d'études spécialisé
dans l'analyse des données sociales des
territoires un observatoire social des
outres mè baptisé coraille a
officiellement été lancé lors de ces
[Musique]
rencontres